Від ранку в лаврі людно. 29 березня УПЦ, яка донедавна називалася
церквою Московського патріархату, має залишити стіни святині.
Сотні людей прийшли, як кажуть, молитися за свою церкву.
Підтримати монахів. - Помолитися за мир, щоб усе було добре,
щоб не було ніяких розколів, ніяких протидій незаконних.
Ну що, ми будемо опиратися, чи що? В рукопашну? Ні, звісно.
Ми прийшли помолитися. Якщо будуть виштовхувати - підемо.
Служба минає спокійно, втім - атмосфера біля храму напружена.
Оце привезли томос і почали битися один з одним.
Це значить сила сатани якась розколола суспільство,
щоб ми отак ненавиділи одне одного.
Прийшов подивитися, як сьогодні реалізується постанова
міністерства культури України про виселення представників РПЦ
з території заповідника КП лавра.
Я не побачив нічого нового. Купа фанатиків, які нічого не бачать.
Вони не бачать, що Онуфрій, який очолює цю церкву, якому вони цілують руки,
є діючим членом синоду РПЦ досі. Вони не бачать,
як благословляється зброя, яка щоденно вбиває наших людей.
- ПЦУ прийде сюди і будуть сидіти тут… Ну, як це не прийде?
- Ти бачив, у якому стані монастир приймав споруди?
Тут у будинках дерева росли. А сюди монахи прийшли і будували.
Я людина не віруюча, я агностик, але мені б дуже хотілося,
щоб держава могла захистити сама себе. А на даний час
у вигляді цього московського патріархату держава-агресор у нас тут перебуває.
Я з Донбасу приїхав. У мене син народився 24 серпня 1991 року,
він ровесник незалежності, як я не буду любити нашу вітчизну?
А мене хочуть в колаборанти, в російські попи записати?
Де написано, що я російський поп? У чому моя вина?
Як довела релігієзнавча експертиза держслужби з етнополітики
та свободи совісті, УПЦ не розірвала канонічні зв'язки з Російською
православною церквою. Представники цієї релігійної організації
десять років безоплатно користувалися приміщеннями та майном лаври.
Нині вони не мають наміру виселятися.
А чого виселятися? Треба молитися.
Наш захист насамперед - це благання Бога простити гріхи наші
та зберегти нас від ворожнечі державної та від ворожнечі народної.
Настоятель монастиря Павло Лебідь, проти якого РНБО запровадила санкції,
повідомив прихожанам, що його церква отримала листа
від Києво-Печерського заповідника. У ньому зазначено,
що виселення з лаври відбудеться 30 березня.
Церква оскаржує розірвання з ними договору про користування лаврою в суді.
Тим не менш тиждень тому DW зафільмувала ось такі кадри:
з приміщень лаври почали вивозити ікони, книги й особисті речі священнослужителів.
У 2013 році за дорученням кабміну Миколи Азарова
Києво-Печерський заповідник уклав договір з УПЦ.
Церкві передали в користування так звану Нижню Лавру. Нині цей договір розривається.
Підстава - неузгоджені новобудови й перебудови.
Наприклад, ось ця брама. У 2015 році її розібрали й побудували завново.
Позицію УПЦ з цього приводу в розмові з DW висловив речник
цієї церкви митрополит Климент. Він наполягав, аби в сюжеті DW
називала ПЦУ церквою Константинопольського патріархату,
якщо його церкву називатимуть "УПЦ Московського патріархату".
Климент переконаний, що розірвання договору з його церквою
на підставі закидів про перебудову об'єкта спадщини ЮНЕСКО незаконне.
Мовляв, з висновками експертної комісії міністерства культури,
яка фіксувала недозволене будівництво, не знайомі.
Наші юристи звернулися до міністерства, до інших відомств
із вимогою оприлюднити результати експертизи, щоб нам ознайомитися.
Нам сказали, що це неможливо, тому що на цю експертизу накладений гриф
для службового користування. Нам пропонують повірити на слово всьому тому,
що заявляють чиновники. А ми віримо в Бога, а не в міністерство культури.
У Києво-Печерському заповіднику знали про всі порушення - і до 2013 року, і після.
Кажуть: інформували про них міністерство культури, але нічого не могли вдіяти.
Ситуація така, що порушення зафіксовані, про них писали,
і давайте так, останні 20 років про порушення в Києво-Печерській лаврі писали,
і постійно казали, чому нічого не робиться. Зараз зробили, а чому лише зараз зробили?
Добре, а якщо б не зараз зробили, через 10 років, щось змінилося б?
Утім, питання не лише в новобудовах. Міністр культури Олександр Ткаченко
натякав, що принциповим є знаходження в лаврі "підсанкційних осіб".
Це, зокрема, намісник лаври Павло Лебідь і керуючий справами УПЦ Антоній Паканич.
Релігієзнавець Ігор Козловський додає: на тлі війни у суспільства
з'явилося чимало питань до УПЦ, афілійованої з РПЦ.
Наприклад, стосовно колаборантів серед священників і зв'язків з Росією.
Стосовно тих самих санкцій - знову ж таки, якщо у вас є такі особи,
церква повинна хоча б розпочати розслідування, чому держава їх зробила
такими персонами, які підпадають під санкції.
Але церква знову ж таки нічого не зробила. Тобто ми не бачимо тих зрушень,
яких очікує і суспільство, і держава. Тому держава зрозуміла
і ставить питання у просторі правовому.
Ключове питання нині: що буде з лаврою далі?
Низка експертів певні, що процес виселення УПЦ (МП) звідти триватиме довго.
Можливо, церква буде відстоювати свої права, можливо, через судові інстанції.
Ми ж розуміємо, що просто так виселяти людей ніхто не буде.
Ми ж не Росія, ми не будемо створювати конфліктні ситуації.
Будуть судові процеси, суд виноситиме рішення.
Як довго це буде тривати - важко сказати.
Чи діятиме в стінах лаври чоловічий монастир?
Чи перетвориться вона виключно на музей?
Митрополит помісної Православної церкви України Епіфаній наголосив,
що підтримує продовження чернечого життя в лаврі.
Хоча поки що про передачу Нижньої лаври в користування ПЦУ не йдеться.
Я також засвідчую братії, що всі з вас, хто послідують вимогам канонів і томосу,
відкинуть беззаконну владу Москви, - продовжать своє служіння в лаврі.
Всі свої можливості та авторитет ми будемо використовувати для того,
щоби захистити вас від залякувань з боку дотеперішнього очільника лаври.
Натомість в УПЦ, яка вважається підлеглою Московському патріархату,
переконані, що після виселення ченців лавра пустуватиме.
Це звернення - це як лебедина пісня Епіфанія, тому що в нього ж ченців немає,
хто ж тут буде жити? Тут у Лаврі 200 ченців і 300 студентів академії проживають.
А в нього на всю Україну 200 ченців. І велике питання, чи вони насправді є.
І хто тут буде жити? А як ми знаємо, природа не терпить пустоти.
І якщо тут нікого не буде, то тут дуже швидко поростуть верби,
і все буде в жалюгідному стані, так як це у Верхній лаврі.
Священник ПЦУ Георгій Коваленко наголошує, що монастир ніхто
не збирається закривати й пустувати він не буде.
Давайте спочатку звільнимо місце, а потім реально побачимо.
Як говориться в приказці, святе місце пустим не буває.
І тому не треба нас лякати тим, що лавра буде пустою.
Вона наповнюється не монахами московського патріархату тільки
- вона наповнюється прочанами, вона наповнюється туристами,
вона наповнюється тими людьми, які бажають туди прийти помолитися.
Крім того, низка фахівців і священників нагадують про історичну традицію
монастиря лаври - коли монахи самі обирали собі архімандрита.
Історик і співробітник Києво-Печерського заповідника Костянтин Крайній
нагадує, що лавра ще з часів заснування була своєрідним незалежним
ні від кого анклавом. Але в 18 столітті, після реформ Катерини другої,
втратила самостійність і можливість обирати своє керівництво.
Саме в кінці XVII століття, коли лавра втрачає свій вплив і свої можливості,
вона стає просто одним з монастирів, з яких імперія свій ідеологічний вплив
розповсюдила на колонізовані землі, на Україну. І саме в цей час,
по-перше, митрополити всі київські лише з російських губерній
сюди призначаються. І вони одночасно стають священноархімандритами лаври.
Лаврі це було особливо образливо, бо до того вони постійно
протистояли митрополитам, а тут вони просто є вже підпорядковані.
Водночас нині від імені братії виступає лише підсанкційний Павло Лебідь,
а ініціатив про самостійність від чернецтва поки не надходило.
Зараз фактично іде боротьба за те, щоб надати суб'єктності
оцій чернечій громаді, самим монахам.
Держава і ПЦУ хочуть, щоб монахи були суб'єктними
і мали свою точку зору і свою думку, а УПЦ (МП) на чолі з Антонієм, Онуфрієм, Павлом
- вони якраз не хочуть, щоб монахи мали суб'єктність,
вони хочуть самі говорити від імені монахів і, власне, вирішувати їхню долю за них.
Якщо вони підуть, то щоб усі монахи пішли.
Священник Георгій Коваленко відзначає: для ченців немає ультиматуму
- перехід в ПЦУ або виселення з лаври. Він так само підтримує самовизначення братії.
З боку ПЦУ пропозиція до діалогу без попередніх умов.
Мета діалогу - єдність українського православ'я.
Це не значить, що хтось кудись має переходити.
Це значить, що давайте вести діалог і давайте знайдемо формат
нашої єдності без попередніх умов. Більше того, сам термін переходу невірний.
Питання в тому, чи долучаєшся ти до єдності, чи в єдності ти з усім
українським православ'ям, чи ти від нього відокремлюєшся.
Поки лавра залишається у власності держави, а саме: Києво-Печерського заповідника.
Хто проводитиме богослужіння в храмах - теж визначатиме заповідник.
Ця ж структура платитиме комунальні рахунки лаври.
Цим його представники дещо занепокоєні, адже йдеться про мільйонні суми.
Ще одне питання - майбутнє пов'язаної з Росією УПЦ в Україні.
У лаврі, кажуть експерти, церква втрачає свій головний актив в Україні.
Ідеться не лише про духовний вплив, а й про прибутки.
Лавра - це великий бізнес-проєкт. По-перше, там є купа різних послуг -
від церковних записок, поминань, свічок, вони на цьому заробляють
дуже добре, тому що це ядро. Ти можеш подати поминання у своєму храмі,
але вважається, що найсильніша молитва в лаврі.
Тому з усієї країни, навіть з-за кордону люди приїжджають,
подають записки на поминання, платять за це гроші, купують свічки,
релігійну атрибутику, літературу. У лаврі є готель, трапезні, де люди харчуються,
є великий штат монахів і ченців, які працюють у сфері цього обслуговування
і навіть на будівельних майданчиках безкоштовно.
У тебе є прибуток, але немає витрат на зарплатний фонд.
Водночас, як кажуть експерти, пов'язана з московським патріархатом УПЦ
- неоднорідна структура. У церкві є й опозиційно налаштоване духовенство,
і щирі прихильники "русского міра", і ті, хто підлаштовується під ситуацію.
За словами фахівців, виселення з лаври може стати стимулом до змін у самій церкві.
Або ця церква сприйме як певну допомогу, намагання держави очистити її від агентів,
і очиститься сама. Бо держава за неї не буде роботу внутрішню робити
щодо її структурування, чи те, як вона має бути влаштована,
чи чим вона має займатися. Якщо вона не буде робити цього очищення,
якщо вона буде чинити спротив українській державі,
українському суспільству, то її чекає маргіналізація.
В Онуфрія є така ідея, що головне - це мале стадо, але вірне стадо.
Тобто йому не важлива кількість вірян, вплив, як вірність,
вірність у таких консервативних ультраконсервативних традиціях.
І все йде до того, що якщо вони будуть і далі відмовлятися
від конструктивних діалогів, то вони перетворяться на ультраконсервативну секту,
яка буде сповідувати середньовічний спосіб життя
і вірити в якісь дурості на кшталт того, як вони заперечували існування коронавірусу.
Також експерти вважають, що після історії з Києво-Печерською лаврою,
може постати питання й щодо храмів УПЦ в Чернігові та Почаєві.